all right
hello everyone
this is my second time speaking at
Tennessee and the first time was during
the pandemic then I was in this small
room all alone talking to a computer
screen
so uh that was pretty lonely so it's
better to have you guys here and not be
the only one in the room
my name is halstein Breton and I work
for a company called novanet based here
in Oslo focusing on.net and azure
and I probably have the most
concrete subject in this conference I'm
going to show you how you can connect an
app service to an Azure SQL database
using manage identity
and without any secrets
I've also written a blog post about this
so if you want the details later you can
go to the no net blog
okay so traditionally the connection
string to the database contains both
username and password in clear text
so that's kind of a security flag right
there you might lose this connection
string
and you don't really know how many
people has it so you don't really know
how many people that can access your
database which is very bad
there are of course some mitigations
done around this you can rotate your
secret you can in Azure you can set up
you have this firewall so you can set up
IP restrictions
and also if using infrastructure as code
you can generate this connection string
during that process during the deployed
process and added to Azure key world and
use it for your service you can use it
directly there and you don't have to
to know about it
but then there's a fire some emergency
in production and you as a developer
need to go into the production database
and do something and then you would need
the fetch the connection string and
it's on your computer and then anything
can happen
so uh
you can guard your secrets as good as
you as you can
but wouldn't it be better to have no
secrets at all
so uh so I firmly believe that secret
less is the way to go
that is the way
and achieving this in Azure uh you can
use this mechanism called managed
identity
and the managed identity is something
that allows your app to easily
access other Azure ad protected
resources like Azure SQL Server Azure
key Vault and the list keeps growing
so that identity is managed and that
means that you don't you don't you don't
have to rotate secrets and all that is
handled
so uh June last year uh Microsoft data
SQL client package version 300 was
released and it leverages the Azure
identity and it handles everything
regarding Azure active directory tokens
renewal and expiration and all that
also
it added this new keyword to the
connection string called Authentication
and this authentication keyword could be
either
Azure directory managed Identity or
active directory default which also
includes
authenticating using visual studio
Visual Studio code Azure CLI and stuff
like that enabling you to do local
development with this
so say hello to your new connection
screen this is the the server is the the
namespace of the SQL Server you got the
name of the database and you got the
authentication method and there are no
secrets here you can put this on your
company website you can check it into
GitHub you can do whatever uh
no secrets
so it's it's time for a demo
um
I've created a SQL server in Azure and
an app service
and I've deployed some code to the app
service
and the code looks like this
is just a minimal API
with the connection string that I just
showed you
and it it runs the query select one
which is a typical health check query
for databases it will just check that
you have a connection
and if you do it will print success
so uh
first thing I'm gonna do this is my app
service it's called NDC demo
uh it's not there
okay now it's here so
uh under settings here you have a an
option called identity
it looks like this and you can assign
either a system aside a signed Identity
or a user assigned identity it doesn't
really matter for this example but this
system assigned identity
follows the life cycle of the app
service
and you can only connect it to one app
the user assigned identity is more of a
separate entity
it has its own life cycle and you can
connect multiple app services or
functions to this user identity which
can be nice if you want to share
the same permissions for multiple app
services
so I'm just gonna click
on and save that will create
a system assigned managed identity for
my app series
like that and we'll it will get the same
name
as the app service so it's it's called
undersea demo
better okay
so uh because this is SQL Server I also
need to create a database user and I
don't have a connection string anymore
so to be able to create a database user
I need to First give myself
permissions and
in
let's see
this is the SQL server in Azure portal
and you have something called Azure
active directory here so you can set an
administrator for your SQL Server and
I've already done this shaded a bit so I
created I never set
stuff like that directly to one user so
I rather want to create a group in
active directory then put myself in the
group and give the permissions to the
group it makes it much more flexible
because you can add and remove people
from that group
so now I've created a group called SQL
admin added myself
set it as administrator for the SQL
server and I also ticked the Box support
only Azure active directory
authentication for this server
so now I should be able to use uh
SQL Server management Studio
to log in
to my database server also I can show
you first that if I go to NDC demo Azure
websites
and that right now it it doesn't work
it will take some time and it won't be
able to connect to the database
so um
I don't know how I can make this one
bigger but instead of using the usual
SQL Server Authentication
[Music]
method to authenticate you can choose
Azure active directory Universal with
multi-factor Authentication
so this is for logging into the SQL
server for my personal user and now I've
gone I've gone from a connection string
with a password in clear text to
actually using multi-factor
authentication logging in with actual
with Azure active directory
thank you
so it will prompt me for a
for a code
which hopefully I will receive
d
so
it's uh
Look Away everyone
okay
seems to be working I'll just move the
correct window here
uh
yeah so this is just uh
showing the SQL Server showing my
database and
I'm sorry that it's a bit small I'm
gonna
create the user
and
the only thing to kind of remember here
is that the name of the user
needs to be
the same as the name of the managed
identity
so NDC demo is the name of the user and
I assign a data reader and data writer
roles in the database
and I run this
and now
if I try to refresh the page
success
so my app service can connect to the SQL
Server
without any secrets
okay back to the presentation
so to summarize
fewer Secrets give you a more secure
system which is a better system
this works in production for my current
project we are using manage identity for
Azure key Vault for Azure service bus
for event Hub iot Hub event grid
everything uses Azure managed identity
so why are why do we have Azure cables
there we have one Secret in Azure key
world
and do you do you want me to tell you
what it is
I can't because then it won't be a
secret anymore
uh no bad joke but uh it's the it's the
API key for sendgrid
so for external secrets of course you
can't use managed identity
then Azure keyboard is perfect for that
but accessing
Azure cable to retrieve those external
secrets
you can use managed identity for that
Okay so
because this requires ad the required
for me to have access to the database I
need to be in an Active Directory Group
so you have actually you know which
persons have access to your to your
database you're using uh multi-factor
authentication to log onto your database
so it's much much more secure
it gives you better control and now I
did some clicking in the portal but
everything is very easy to set up using
infrastructure as code
also downsides I was told that I need to
have downsides otherwise the upsides
wouldn't count
so uh using Azure role-based
Authentication
uh it does require you to create a lot
of roles the
for the app service to be able to use
Azure keyboard read from a topic in
Azure service bus
use app configuration you would need
different roles for the application so
that role hierarchy can grow to be quite
big
so that's something that you need to
kind of have a plan on how to manage
also for local development
there might be a bit tedious because you
would need some permissions yourself as
well then you would typically create ad
groups called developers or something
and give permissions to that group
which is also kind of a good thing
because then you would know
it will be clear which permissions that
the developers has in having the system
okay so my time is up uh I hope I have
inspired you to go secret Less in the
future
and thanks for listening
[Applause]